all right let's go back to the phones
and see what's on folks minds let's go
to our caller from the 95 to area code
who's calling today from nine five two
okay yes I can hey David Mike so my
question was so given all of the sort of
recent events that occurred in the news
cycle such as like the whistleblower
complaint against Donald Trump Tim sure
all the individuals that are implicated
in this complaint such as my campaign do
bullion bar and the fact that there's
even a cover-up
what's associated with some of the calls
that Trump has made Trump still seems to
maintain and about a forty percent
approval rating I mean what do you think
the reason is that people still will
ardently defend them and what do you
think it would take for voters or
supporters of his to finally flip I
don't think that so here's the thing he
has a floor of support I don't know if
it's like 27 or 26 or 32 or something
like that
who will never flip it doesn't matter
what he does as he has said if he shot
someone on Fifth Avenue they still
wouldn't flip you can then add to that
Republicans who just really hate
Democrats and are just going to say they
approve of the job that Donald Trump is
doing so you're gonna have that group
and then you've got people who are just
not super keyed in and they lack
information about what's going on it's
just sort of like yeah I guess my life's
not bad so I guess I guess I approve and
that's how you get yourself to 40
percent with a president that is this
embroiled in scandal and potential
criminality and immorality that's how
it's constructed Brett it almost seems
like unprecedented zone since that it
doesn't seem like any other you know
candidate has enjoyed the kind of
support or the kind of base that Trump
has like it's almost like a religious to
the fervor that his base has for him
like what do you think that is like what
do you think that comes from I you know
I think I don't know that it's that
unique maybe to this degree but it's
like George W Bush his approval rating
did go very low at one point but he had
a base and then it recovered very
quickly Barack Obama's approval in that
one never went below a certain level and
we don't it wasn't tested whether he had
an unflinching base so I don't know that
it's that unique in the hyper partes
20:19 but there's definitely people who
are just where I love Trump that's it
yeah I guess what I'm trying to get that
too is I mean there's so much clearly
wrong with Trump and there's so so much
manifestly just disorganized in his mind
and like he just didn't like a very
unwell person yeah so at the very least
you could say george w bush has been
near of being at least a normal human
being the functioning model right but
you can't really say the same about
Donald Trump it just seems very odd that
people can love someone that's so
clearly just a deluded narcissist it
just doesn't make sense I completely
agree with you and you know what I would
suggest is go talk to some of those
people who support him and listen to the
answers they give you and you'll very
quickly I understand what's going on
right you know funny you say that
because my grandfather is a big Trump
supporter hmm sad to bring it up just
don't email me situations to make things
awkward but I get it sort of like
there's a cynicism in his support read
that everything is just so bad Trump is
honest about everything being so bad if
that makes any sense like and that
there's almost like an emotional
connection to that sort of hate for the
establishment and I think like sort of
mainstream yeah it's like the right word
I'm definitely the idea of Trump is the
guy who's trolling people and and some
contingent of his likes that and that's
also extraordinarily disturbing right
and sorry if I'm gonna take it easy up
to this side but it's one last statement
I think too is that there's like sort of
like older generation sort of sees like
the young up-and-coming Democrats is
sort of like a threat that sort of
almost seems like in a sense like a
dying gasoline Silent Generation kind of
trying to cling on to power and keep
things as the way they were that's
interesting that maybe but we won't know
for like another 15 years right all
right well thank you so much every time
okay thanks I appreciate the phone call
great to hear from you